now if your bank Holly plans have been
scuppered by the lockdown how about
spending tomorrow all of tomorrow
listening to a live reading of the
hobbits it's being read by the actor
Andy Serkis who of course played Gollum
in the Lord of the Rings trilogy he's
going to be reading The Hobbit from
cover to cover to raise money for the
NHS well I'm delighted to say we can
speak to Andy now Andy good afternoon
hello how are you yeah I'm very well
thank you I'm very excited about your
Hobbit Earth on tomorrow and I remember
reading the book at school and it took
me ages to really cover to cover in one
sitting how long is it gonna take you um
well I think I've estimated that it's
gonna take between 10 and 12 hours so it
is it is exactly that it's a hobbit
athon and the idea was that it was
really an ode to everyone who's been
stuck inside who's been trapped to who
craves adventure who craves getting out
and escaping and and who physically
can't and the emotional ravages that
that's having on them I mean I'm a very
outdoors person and I love climbing and
and doing mountains and being in nature
and the very fact that you know this
this disease has prevented people from
stepping outside of their own front
doors I just wanted to take people on
this extraordinary adventure one of the
greatest ever written quite frankly of
self-discovery as well as as well as
experiencing an imaginary fantasy world
yeah it really is escapism it's
adventure it's about an epic journey
nobody can go on epic journeys at the
moment and but it's interesting that
you're going to do it in one sitting 10
to 12 hours how many characters are in
The Hobbit because of course you're
you're famous for playing Gollum in that
franchise and very well and how are you
coping with some of the other characters
because presumably you've been doing a
bit of practice ahead of this I've had
to do a bit of training it is much like
a marathon you know yeah you know I've
been building up the amount of pages
every day make sure my my larynx doesn't
get chafed and
you know that I keep it lubricated you
know it's it is I'm aware that you know
and the difference with this is it's not
like an audio recording or a book
recording where you can go back and edit
this is this is live so there's as you
know as you're pointing out you know
there are lots of different characters
and I can't remember exactly how many
but of course you know there's there's
there's all the dwarfs there's Bilbo
Baggins there's Gandalf there's all of
the orcs and all of the goblins and
countless other minor characters so so
it is it's gonna be you know it's gonna
be an adventure for me too as I'm going
through and and and bringing hopefully
bringing those things to life for
everybody I hope you're ready because I
know you say 10 to 12 hours but I'm just
thinking about storytime in households
up and down the country for kids at
night when parents and relatives get
into the character and a chapter you
think I'll always take about 10 minutes
always takes longer when you get into it
so how are you gonna keep yourself going
like I said it's like training for a
marathon but once you're in that hobbit
of film what's your strategy well you
know obviously there are lots of things
to consider what you do the amount
you've got to drink and to keep your
throat lubricated there's there's you
know obviously I'm gonna get hungry at
some point but the good thing is of
course hobbits will be coming in city
for eating lots so so I can I think I
think the idea is that everyone gathers
around it's a bit like a storytelling
session where you can bring bring food
I'm encouraging people to bring snacks
sit there and then maybe we can all
chomp for a bit in between chapters and
then move on depending on the tension
and where we've got to with the story
there will of course be there will be
moments where a comfort break is
necessary I'm imagining and so we'll
have to figure out that one as it
happens but the idea as I say yeah I
don't remember that in the hobbit if my
if my cats wander in and sit on top of
the laptop then then and cause all sorts
of mayhem that may well be part of it
too it's a live event is the perils of
broadcasting from home Andy I tell you
I'm sitting far too close to my front
door I'm dreading the doorbell going off
at one point or another and but talk to
me about why you're doing this because
you want to raise money for good causes
and what I love
is that you're inspired by captain Tom
more and watching him there'll be books
and films made about him in years to
come I mean you know what a story the
latter stages of his life have turned
out to be certainly he's a legendary
figure he will probably be the archetype
that people will remember from this it's
this time you know that the heroic
character and and such a you know you
know not to compare him to Bilbo Baggins
but but being an ordinary person and you
know this this story is all about about
every one of us overcoming our own
challenges our own individual you know
what we're learning from what we're
learning from these experiences so it's
it's really I I was inspired by it by
captain Tom now Colonel Tom and I just
thought if he can if he can walk or you
know a hundred laps around his garden at
the age of a hundred I can get through
300 or whatever it is 367 pages of The
Hobbit
this is that this is a mere a mere kind
of ode to to captain Tom but but never
that I said to I it is that thing of
what the human spirit is capable of
doing that that was inspirational and
you're raising money for NHS charities
together one of your favorite charities
you've been involved with for a number
of years best beginnings can you tell us
a little bit about that charity we're
running out of time but also how people
can actually watch you tomorrow and
donate yes
and so best beginnings as a child health
charity which covers for a preach for
parents and children from prenatal
through to early years people who are
have lack of access to information and
in that very lonely in tender moment of
around childbirth pre and post
especially underprivileged and
disenfranchised families or individuals
who are going through pregnancy and
young young years of their child
especially in times like these and
obviously charities have deeply affected
by loss of income for you know for that
individual charities the NHS of course
it's this is very much about supporting
them to continue to support them for the
whilst we're inside and safe in our
indoors they are
fighting if every second of the data to
make sure that we come out of this so
the this will go out on a link which
will be released tomorrow morning at
8:00 a.m. it will go if you want to
donate you can go to WWE my comm The
Hobbit athan covered 19 appeal and I you
know I'm aware that people have given
hugely to charities but and people may
not but even if they just want to enjoy
the story in the escape that's fine fine
by me that's part of it too but if they
can yeah a little bit counts as much as
a lot Andy thank you so much Andy Serkis